a lot of people been asking me jake how
are you so effing relatable man how are
you so effing funny how do you know so
much about tax evasion it's like a
suspicious amount right shoot just
burned my eggs except i didn't
because this is a green screen everyone
knows that the best way to grow your
channel is to form a parasocial bond
with your viewers i may not know them
but they seem to know me
so what is a parasocial relationship
so they are social want to establish a
parasocial relationship with your
audience here's some tricks first you
have to be relatable that's why so many
of you comment hashtag so relatable
under so many of my viral videos second
don't be too relatable that's why so
many of you comment why is this on my
feed and shut the [ __ ] up you piece of
peace
um
you guys say that a lot third don't let
people know too much about you and what
they do know make sure it's vague enough
so that people can project their own
interests onto you see this gamecube you
probably think i had some fun times
playing it in my youth this isn't my
gamecube i stole this from a child
fourth never be sincere online if people
can't tell if you're joking or not they
can't blame you for anything you say did
i change my shirt three times during
this video or is it just a continuity
error
i'll never say finally step five never
admit your weaknesses it reminds people
of their own weaknesses
this isn't hard for me because i have
no weaknesses so if you do all of this
maybe just maybe you will cultivate an
audience that will someday
buy your 80 merch
you